WELCOME BACK EVERYBODY!
TO LWIAY!!
LWIAY!
Don't worry about....
What's happening he- Oh what is this?
(R.I.P metal thingy in the background, we will miss you)
(best intro, if your reading this....... im kinda bored........)
These are programmable lights.
For every blink, for every blink
You get really... really
H A P P Y
Roll the intro!
(beautiful song intro thingy....)
LWIAY! LWIAY!
Everyone's favorite show! "When is the next LWIAY coming out?"
Soon... Now! it's out now. Welcome, everybody to YouTube's favorite show LWIAY.
Where I go through funny pictures and go "haha"
That you guys made. You guys make the pictures...
This is the show where I ask the questions and you guys do the answers.
This is the show where I make the original content, and you give me the answers.
O H H!
This week we got a lot of great ones. My god. I-i've been sneak peeking... don't tell anyone.
Another chair meme everybody *clap clap*
*laughs*
Hey old school bros! Remember Mr. Chair?
This is him now. Feel old yet? Well it...
Damn.
Oh, this is someone else's setup.
That looked like MY old setup.
Th-that confused me. Well done! Hey look at that? Someone paid $399!
Oh, it's almost like people can actually afford the chair, and you're just a crybaby!
Can your chair do this?
(BUT CAN YOU DO THIIIIIIIIISSSSSSSSSSSSSSSSSSSSSS?!?!?!?!?!?!?!?!?!?!?!?)
Don't think so!
$300 *laughs* Look at this. Look at these crybabies.
I can't even get to one meme from anoth- who's texting me? I have no friends (is Marzia and your fans nothing now?, i see how you really feel :(
$300 for a chair, that's not typically the amount you would pay. Have you completely lost touch with reality?
Yes, I know, bUT CAN YOU DO THIS?
How many time am I gonna do this?
As many- Jesus! I almost flew back
You don't see me- eh. Oh! *falls back* (BUT CAN YOU....... FALL OVER BACKWARDS ON YOUR CHAIR?????)
Oh man, Thor looks amazing in the new 'Avengers: Infinity War' movie.
That's right. I am actually Swedish
Unlike Chris Hemsworth. Fake Swestian.
Felix should make a 'Pewdiepie' phone.
You smartphones think you're so great huh?
But can you do this? *laughs*
Why is this the only meme?
My fu- *laughs*
it is the only meme because..... IT CAN DO THIS
God damn it. **christian channel**
Ow. Alright here we go. We have a girl. (make good choices poods...)
Um yeah. This happened all the time. Back in the day, of course.
Faithful Swestian
2013 pewds equals best pewds...
*Sad Romance by Ji PyeongKeyon*
I think i have something on my tongue.
Oh! That is so cute. I think Edgar would have a great role in getting over it.
Can we get an Edgar modpack for 'Getting Over It'?
That's awesome. I would love to see that.
Kawaii desu ne.
Which one doesn't belong? The star? The bell? (Ornament) The polka thing? (Candy cane)
That's right. You don't hang the star.
*clap*
Oh! That is-
E   D   G   Y
*reads the comic*
*internalized oppression*
*rethinking his life*
is Bike Cuck making...
dank memes now?
W-what is this? What is happening?
I've seen this one...
It's a- it's a top notch... top notch meme. Good job, whoever reposted this.
Congrats. What do you want a medal?
1997: Don't sit too close to the TV it will damage your eyes
2017:
Yeah, I do feel like Oculus must mess with your eyes, right?
There's no way it can be healthy.
Why am I discussing this on LWIAY™?
No one gives a shit. (christian channel)
Hey Monica! Hey on you Monica!
When you realize your favorite youtuber has finally lost it *laughs*(oh i thought that was a known fact...)
It's a good song okay? I get entranced every time I sing it, you know?
The other countries have their national anthem...
Swestian in channel has: hej, hej, Monica. hej på dig (hey on you) Monica.
Found Felix's headquarters
Sorry sir, this is a Christian building so no swearing.
*chuckle* Oh, it's my headquarters. Yeah, yeah. Of course.
Wait, didn't Lushsux do like...
Why did no one post this one?
Come on, man!
Even filled out my beard... so nicely!
Lushsux, you- you're the best.
People doing cool stunts with wheelchairs. Oh wow, that's pretty good
*sudden realization*
Why?
W  H  Y
*laughs*
So good 8 out of 10 very nice
5 out of 10 needs more crippling depression
Christian channel! Depression is not a joke, okay?
Just look at this... Natsuki meme- *dies of laughter*
*reads the meme*
Th-
Listen... Where's my phone?
It's a great phone for gaming! (oh reaaaally?)
Getting Over It with Pewdiepie:
This game, hard?
*laughs*
I WILL beat the game. You guys don't understand...
You keep saying, "Oh you sh- you should quit! The hardest part hasn't even begun!"
This is not me playing Getting Over It...
This is me turning into my true form, MY GOD-LIKE FORM, my sentient being...I'm charging my chakra!
*reading*
OH OKAY. You think-
*gets the mousepad*
Looks like someone's got a new trick up his sleeve!
(Pewds...you need help.)
No more small mousepad BS...
THIS TIME, thank you!
*reading* (christian channel)
*laughs*
The last "You Laugh, You Lose" got passed with no problem. I've never seen anything like it...
I was like, "This is a miracle. This is a Christian miracle."
I-i thought it would unlock something! You know...
like a forbidden... forbidden ability!
Like your videos will upload just fine
but no... NO WE WON'T.
*reading*
What am I gonna do, NOT answer the door?
Blame my editors, okay?
"oh yeah your edits are always so good, Felix. Who edits your videos?"
Oh, yeah, okay?
I need to open the door. They leave it in...
"oh, they're so great!"
I'll do one weird thing off-camera, and I tell them "Hey! Don't put this in."
...they put it in!
WHY IS EVERYONE AGAINST MEEEE!
*reads*
I bet you he can't!
Excuse me. I am the visual novel adaptation. Get it right.
*reads*
We are now entering...
The last page of memes.
This is where the good stuff is.
This is the top of the salt mine.
*laughs in dollars*
Goddamn it... **christian channel**
But where are the armrests huh? and the lumbar support?
*claps* Finally, you get it!
You okay? You cool? Jesus Christ! (christian channel)
Nice...nice.
Uhh...
I really appreciate the creativity that comes out of petting dog memes.
It is... it is at the end of the- end of the line.
It's a dying bloodline of memes but...
Every once in a while you see your nice one and you go, "Ha."
*reads*
You're goddamn, right! **christian channel**
Rest in peace, Slippy. (awwww...)
That is so cute. (yes it is.)
He's there with Steve Irwin, and all the other memes, aww...
Oh, everyone's pressing F for respect. AWWWWWWWW
*reads*
Well done, GODDAMN IT. **christian channel**
That was this week of...
LWIAY! LWIAY!
Post some memes for next week...
And you can- you can have the honor of being immortalized...
...in the Pewdiepie video (all of the ones in the parenthesies were me GET IT RIGHT.... AHHHHHHHHHH)   (sorry)
You can put that on your curriculum: "I was featured in Pewdiepie's video..."
"...world's largest *cough* subscribing channel."
Not a dying Channel. Thank you very much, okay?
And remember to leave a like and have a smile.
*memories of Slippy start flooding in*  (slipy :((((  .....)